Frost has this very algorithmic-oriented style of, like, it works with iterators, it composes into different algorithms, right? So, like, some algorithms are implemented in terms of other algorithms, and it has this nice touch, right? Whereas when you go into Cobb, it's just full of, like, C-style cars, reinterpreting type-alizing. It has, like, every kind of U.B that you can imagine, which is why I think Cobb actually stands for Cuda undefined behavior, right? It's, Cub is specific to our platform, which means it's not, like, we, NVIDIA, make the platform. Yeah, the parrot thing, well, just, I am now, I have a second daughter now, and as things go, I can make a lot of dead jokes now, so, so Sean Parrott. Congratulations. There's a conversation to be had at a later date about API design and the importance of an ergonomic and
Thrust 有一种非常算法导向的风格，比如它使用迭代器，并将其组合成不同的算法，对吧？所以，有些算法是基于其他算法实现的，这很有意思，对吧？而当你进入 Cobb 时，它到处都是 C 风格的转换，重新解释类型转换。它有你能想象到的各种未定义行为（U.B），这就是为什么我认为 Cobb 其实代表 Cuda undefined behavior（Cuda 未定义行为），对吧？它是，Cub 是我们平台特有的，这意味着它不是，我们，NVIDIA，制造了这个平台。是的，关于鹦鹉（parrot）的事，嗯，只是，我现在，我有第二个女儿了，随着事情的发展，我现在可以讲很多冷笑话了，所以，所以 Sean Parrott。恭喜。关于 API 设计以及符合人体工程学和
intuitive interface. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 261 recorded on October 10, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, We continue our conversation live from C++ Under the Sea in the Netherlands. In this episode, we chat with Bernhard, a fellow Envidian from Austria, Kuhn from Belgium for the third time, C++, 26 Reflection, and more. We got another Invidium. Oh, hi.
直观界面的重要性，以后还有机会讨论。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 261 期，录制于 2025 年 10 月 10 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们继续在荷兰的 C++ Under the Sea 大会上进行现场对话。在这一集中，我们与来自奥地利的 NVIDIA 同事 Bernhard，第三次做客的来自比利时的 Kuhn，以及 C++ 26 反射等话题进行了交流。我们又来了一位 NVIDIA 同事。哦，嗨。
You can also explain how great extorts are going to do. Oh, no, I'm not explaining that because I might get it wrong. I have to check up how it works again. Okay, my name is Bernhardt. I joined in video one and a half years ago. I started out in Cobb, but since then, I think I took over maintaining Frost as well, and I have my hands in Lipku Plus, plus, and I think by now I kind of do everything. Right.
你也可以解释一下 extorts 会有多棒。哦，不，我不会解释那个，因为我可能会弄错。我得再查查它是怎么工作的。好的，我叫 Bernhardt。我一年半前加入 NVIDIA。我起初是在做 Cobb，但从那以后，我想我也接手了 Thrust 的维护工作，而且我也参与了 Libcu++，我想现在我基本上什么都做。没错。
He's in everything, man, folks. He does everything. What do you like better? Cover thrust. Ooh, good question. They have very different styles. What I like about Frost, like... He dodged the question, folks.
他什么都做，伙计们。他什么都做。你更喜欢哪个？Cobb 还是 Thrust？噢，好问题。它们的风格非常不同。我喜欢 Thrust 的地方，比如……他回避了这个问题，伙计们。
Well done. You're a future politician. So Frost has this very algorithmic-oriented style of, like, it works with iterators, it composes into different algorithms, right? So, like, some algorithms are implemented in terms of other algorithms, and it has this nice touch, right? Whereas when you're going to Kaab, it's just full of, like, C-style cars, reinterpreting type-elizing.
干得好。你是个未来的政治家。所以 Thrust 有这种非常算法导向的风格，比如，它使用迭代器，并将其组合成不同的算法，对吧？所以，有些算法是基于其他算法实现的，这很有意思，对吧？而当你进入 Kaab 时，它到处都是 C 风格的转换，重新解释类型转换。
It has, like, every kind of U.B that you can imagine, which is why I think Kaab actually stands for KUDA undefined behavior, right? It's, Cub is specific to our platform, which means it's not, like, we, Envidia make the platform. CUB is the implementation. And so we're allowed to do, like, look, if you're within the standard library, the standard library implementer is allowed to do whatever they want. It's not UB because you're the standard library. You better not do anything that's going to break. But CUB is only runs on our platform, and it's provided by the vendor, which means there's no UB and Cubs.
它有你能想象到的各种未定义行为，这就是为什么我认为 Kaab 其实代表 KUDA undefined behavior，对吧？它是，Cub 是我们平台特有的，这意味着它不是，我们，NVIDIA 制造了这个平台。CUB 是实现。所以我们被允许做，比如，看，如果你在标准库内，标准库实现者被允许做任何他们想做的事。这不是未定义行为，因为你是标准库。你最好不要做任何会破坏它的事情。但 CUB 只在我们的平台上运行，并且由供应商提供，这意味着 CUB 中没有未定义行为。
it's all just like the only thing that my cub might have is some undocumented behavior about how it works but i do think that the cub block level primitives can be very nice to work with they're very nice abstraction they're very nice on the outside just don't you know have to look on the inside but uh but yeah what what does cub i mean that's really not what cubs stands for right i assume not it's what yeah cuda unbound okay cuda unbound yes what what were you what were saying the joke was What do you mean? You miss the joke? Yeah, I did.
它只是，我的 CUB 可能有的唯一东西就是关于它如何工作的一些未记录的行为，但我确实认为 CUB 的块级原语非常好用，它们是非常好的抽象，它们在外部看起来非常好，只是你不需要，你知道，去查看内部，但是，嗯，但是是的，CUB 到底是什么意思，我的意思是那真的不是 CUB 代表的意思，对吧？我假设不是，它是，什么，是的，CUDA unbound，好的，CUDA unbound，是的，你刚才说那个笑话是什么意思？你是说你没听懂那个笑话？是的，我没听懂。
What was the joke? Oh, the joke was that I think Cobb could stand for Cuda undefined behavior because it contains so much of that. But I fully agree with Price's analysis before that because we know the tool chain that Cup runs on, right? Like, we know the NVCC versions that the process cop. We know, like, the behavior of our compiler. So we have leeway in what we can write there because we know how the compiler. processes and translates our code yeah and the the biggest problem like the biggest source of ub that
那个笑话是什么？噢，那个笑话是我认为 Cobb 可能代表 Cuda undefined behavior，因为它包含了太多那种东西。但我完全同意 Bryce 之前的分析，因为我们知道 CUB 运行的工具链，对吧？比如，我们知道处理 CUB 的 NVCC 版本。我们知道，比如，我们编译器的行为。所以我们在编写代码时有回旋余地，因为我们知道编译器是如何处理和转换我们的代码的。是的，而且最大的问题，比如 CUB 中最大的未定义行为来源
we've probably had in cub has been like initialization problems and that's largely been requirements change when cub was originally written it was largely designed to work only with plain old data types and with things that it could assume could be left uninitialized or not zero initialized because there was a cost to it it was only later on as cub evolved and cub became the back end for thrust in particular that Cubs, that the requirements have to change and that Cubs then had to really support, you know, arbitrary user-defined types. And at that point where, you know, like all of the places where we just assumed that everything was int-like, you know, became a problem. Or like another good example would be the fact that CUB defaults to 32-bit indexing,
可能就是初始化问题，这很大程度上是因为需求发生了变化。当 CUB 最初编写时，它主要设计为仅与普通旧数据类型（POD）一起工作，以及那些可以假设保持未初始化或不进行零初始化的事物，因为那样会有成本。直到后来，随着 CUB 的演进，特别是当 CUB 成为 Thrust 的后端时，需求不得不改变，CUB 必须真正支持，你知道，任意用户定义的类型。在那个时候，你知道，所有我们假设一切都像 int 一样的地方，你知道，就成了问题。或者另一个很好的例子是 CUB 默认使用 32 位索引，
which has caused, you know, some amount of pain over the years. But, like, recent versions of cup now fully support 64-bit size and offset types or we internally choose right like we check what kind of size type you pass in we can dispatch an implementation that can handle large offsets and it will it will do an efficient thing and it will do a correct thing where did you uh where did you work before invidia and wait got to let these guys finish their chicken nuggets and also too we haven't said uh or you both haven't said where you're based because we this is the first time we've ever had four invidians at once. Jared, we peaked at three.
这在过去几年中造成了一些痛苦。但是，比如，CUB 的最新版本现在完全支持 64 位大小和偏移类型，或者我们在内部选择，对吧，我们检查你传入的大小类型，我们可以分派一个能够处理大偏移量的实现，它会做高效的事情，也会做正确的事情。你在加入 NVIDIA 之前在哪里工作？等等，得让这些家伙吃完他们的鸡块。还有，你们俩还没说你们在哪里办公，因为这是我们第一次同时有四位 NVIDIA 同事。Jared，我们之前最多只有三个。
And so now we've got four. But we're in the Netherlands right now. He said that's a quatro in case. That's an invidio joke if you miss that, folks. But yeah, tell us where you're based, because we're not in America right now. I mean, both of us are basically now the German team at CCL. No.
所以现在我们有四个了。但我们现在在荷兰。他说那是“quatro”，以防万一。如果你没听懂，那是个 NVIDIA 的笑话，伙计们。但是的，告诉我们你们在哪里办公，因为我们现在不在美国。我的意思是，我们俩现在基本上是 CCL 的德国团队。不。
The Europe team? At cup, let's say that. There's more Germans. So for the record, I'm based in Austria, which is no longer part of Germany. You know, there have been times, but that has been long ago, right? I'm based in Austria, fully remote, working there for the CCCL team maintaining Cobb, Frost, and Libku Plus Plus. I actually do live in the countryside, like, in a very small town, a 1,700 inhabitants.
欧洲团队？在 CUB，就这么说吧。德国人更多。所以郑重声明，我在奥地利办公，它不再是德国的一部分了。你知道，曾经有过一段时间，但那是很久以前的事了，对吧？我在奥地利办公，完全远程，在那里为 CCCL 团队工作，维护 Cobb、Thrust 和 Libcu++。我实际上住在乡下，在一个非常小的镇上，有 1700 名居民。
I lived in the mountains. The sound of the music, you know, like the woman, like, dancing, singing, on the hills that's that's for what bryce said about the sound of music is the most american thing that you could think about of austria but it's entirely true like uh like just last weekend uh we we organized that the baptism of my son and we went there in little hos and and those uh shirts right like as you would see in in the movie so that's not a lie i actually watched the movie with my wife a couple years ago because people for the first time right because it's not a thing that the austrians know a lot about right there are better movies to watch exactly absolutely so so we figured we have to
我住在山上。《音乐之声》，你知道，就像那个女人，在山上跳舞、唱歌，那是 Bryce 说的关于《音乐之声》的内容，这是你能想到的关于奥地利最美国化的事情，但它完全是真的。比如，就在上周末，我们组织了我儿子的洗礼，我们穿着皮裤（Lederhosen）和那些衬衫，对吧，就像你在电影里看到的那样，所以那不是谎言。我实际上几年前和我的妻子看了那部电影，因为人们是第一次看，对吧，因为这不是奥地利人很了解的东西，对吧？有更好的电影可以看，确实，绝对是。所以我们想我们必须
finally watch that and it's actually a nice movie it's well done and it shows beautiful pictures of my country there's that one song where she's spinning around on the hilltop very beautiful very beautiful can you sing any of the songs are you uh no he's never he's seen it once unfortunately no i'm not a good singer and i also can do like like traditional dances or or like mountain communication, you know, with big horns or something like, no, no, I'm not, I'm not skilled in this. Here's a little ADSP, you know, inside knowledge. I mean, Bryce probably doesn't know this either. I have three sisters, and when I was younger, my mother, a massive sound of music fan, massive musical fan,
终于看了一次，它确实是一部不错的电影，制作精良，展示了我国家美丽的画面。里面有一首歌，她在山顶上旋转，非常美，非常美。你会唱里面的任何歌吗？你是……不，他从来没看过，他只看过一次，不幸的是，不，我不是个好歌手，我也不会跳传统舞蹈，或者像山地交流，你知道，用大号角之类的，不，不，我不擅长这个。这里有个小小的 ADSP 内部知识。我的意思是，Bryce 可能也不知道这一点。我有三个姐妹，当我年轻的时候，我的母亲，一个《音乐之声》的超级粉丝，超级音乐剧粉丝，
she would torture the four children that she had by making us perform songs from the sound of music. So we would have, we would all have to line up in the living room. And sing her favorite was the final song where they do the goodbyes in different languages. Adieu to you and you and you and you. So long, farewell, I'll be to say adieu. Adieu, adieu, to you and you and you. And then you'd have to like flip and flat. I'm pretty sure that's either child abuse or forbidden by the Geneva Convention.
她会折磨她拥有的四个孩子，让我们表演《音乐之声》里的歌曲。所以我们都得在客厅排成一排。然后唱她最喜欢的那首，他们在最后用不同语言告别的歌。Adieu to you and you and you and you. So long, farewell, I'll be to say adieu. Adieu, adieu, to you and you and you. 然后你还得像那样翻跟头。我敢肯定那要么是虐待儿童，要么是被日内瓦公约禁止的。
I appreciate that. I feel seen. Thank you, Bryce. Because we all didn't like it. And my mother, I love you, Mom. You're not listening to this because I know you don't find this podcast interesting. But if you for some reason end up listening to this, yeah, we never liked it. And we all, you told us that we had to do it as your children.
我很感激。我觉得被理解了。谢谢你，Bryce。因为我们都不喜欢它。而我的母亲，我爱你，妈妈。你没在听这个，因为我知道你觉得这个播客没意思。但如果你因为某种原因最终听到了这个，是的，我们从来都不喜欢它。而且我们都，你告诉我们作为你的孩子必须这样做。
But it wasn't really. All right, all right. That was the question that initially was asked before I interrupted to say, where are you guys based? So where did you work before you were at in video? Right. So before I joined NVIDIA, I did a PhD at CERN, which is a particle physics facility. It's actually the largest. It has a name usually. It's in Switzerland, in Geneva, and we have huge machineries. Like, we have an underground particle collider that's 27 kilometers in circumference. Massive detectors there, like tens of thousands of tons of underground silicon that just measure a particle collider. and it's full of radiation and high voltage equipment, liquid helium everywhere, and it's just awesome. It was safer than working on Cub. That's a good question.
但这并不是真的。好了，好了。那是刚才我打断你们问“你们在哪里办公”之前提出的问题。所以你们在加入 NVIDIA 之前在哪里工作？好的。在加入 NVIDIA 之前，我在欧洲核子研究中心（CERN）攻读博士学位，那是一个粒子物理设施。它实际上是最大的。它通常有个名字。它在瑞士日内瓦，我们有巨大的机器。比如，我们有一个周长 27 公里的地下粒子对撞机。那里有巨大的探测器，比如数万吨的地下硅，只是为了测量粒子对撞机。而且它充满了辐射和高压设备，到处都是液氦，这真是太棒了。它比在 CUB 工作更安全。这是个好问题。
I think we had a, we also had a good share of undefined behavior. Maybe for, in the defense of CERN, like, you had to do appropriate trainings before you could go into dangerous areas. Whether when I started out at Envid, he immediately left me into the code base, completely untrained and unprepared. of the horrors that I would see there. How did you end up at NVIDA? Because Paul was saying that he was using CCCL before. He was a contributor and then he found his way. What was, were you a similar path or, you know, CERN just gets you a job at NVIDIA?
我想我们也有，我们也有相当多的未定义行为。也许为 CERN 辩护一下，比如，你在进入危险区域之前必须进行适当的培训。而当我刚开始在 NVIDIA 工作时，他立刻就把我放进了代码库，完全没有经过培训，也没有准备好面对我在那里会看到的恐怖。你是怎么最终来到 NVIDIA 的？因为 Paul 说他之前一直在使用 CCCL。他是一名贡献者，然后他找到了自己的路。你是类似的路径吗，还是说，CERN 只是让你在 NVIDIA 找到了一份工作？
Like what a... Oh, no. So, so many years back, I spared a whole life story, right? But I'm doing C++ for quite a long time. And around 2019, I attended my first C++ comedy meeting. And... I thought you said comedy for a second. comedy.
就像一个……噢，不。所以，很多年前，我省去了整个人生故事，对吧？但我做 C++ 已经很长时间了。大约在 2019 年，我参加了我的第一次 C++ 委员会会议。而且……我以为你刚才说了喜剧（comedy）。喜剧。
What am I? They are funny. Maybe that wasn't a misspell, right? So I went to a committee meeting and I fell in love with the language before. I really liked it. I kind of like grew into the C++ community. And when I was at CERN, I further developed my skills in C++ and eventually kind of like grew into high performance computing, where we also did some GPGPU computing. And when the Ph.D. kind of ended, you know, you ask yourself, like, what job can I imagine?
我是什么？他们很有趣。也许那不是拼写错误，对吧？所以我去参加了委员会会议，我之前就爱上了这门语言。我有点像是在 C++ 社区中成长起来的。当我在 CERN 时，我进一步发展了我的 C++ 技能，最终成长为高性能计算领域，我们也做了一些 GPGPU 计算。当博士学位快结束时，你知道，你会问自己，我能想象什么样的工作？
What company could I see myself working for? I knew I didn't want to continue in academia, so I wondered what kind of company, you know, is invested in the C++ community, cares about that language. Probably does GPU and care about performance and can maybe employ me in Austria, fully remote, because I wanted to move back from Switzerland because my wife and me were about to start a family. And that didn't leave a lot of options there, right? So I figured Nvidia was a natural choice that could combine all these interests and provide a nice place to work for. Didn't I, we met for like the second or third time when I came to CERN to give a talk. And then I was like, we got to hire this guy.
我能想象自己在什么样的公司工作？我知道我不想继续在学术界工作，所以我好奇什么样的公司，你知道，投资于 C++ 社区，关心那门语言。可能做 GPU 并且关心性能，并且可能在奥地利雇佣我，完全远程，因为我想从瑞士搬回来，因为我和我妻子正准备组建家庭。那里的选择不多，对吧？所以我认为 NVIDIA 是一个自然的选择，可以结合所有这些兴趣，并提供一个好的工作场所。我们不是第二次或第三次见面时，我去了 CERN 做演讲吗？然后我就想，我们得雇佣这个家伙。
And then I was like, I just like poke people. Was that time you heard on the podcast and you mentioned that you had gone to CERN? Yes, that was, yeah. And I just, well, Bernard gave. That means you've worked here for less than five years, probably, like three or four. Yeah, probably. Is that accurate? Oh, I started at a video one and a half years ago.
然后我就想，我只是去戳戳人。那是你在播客上听到并提到你去过 CERN 的那次吗？是的，那是，是的。我只是，嗯，Bernhard 给出的。这意味着你在这里工作不到五年，可能三四年。是的，可能。准确吗？噢，我一年半前加入 NVIDIA。
Okay, yeah, yeah. So there's actually, there's an even better part of the story, which is that when I went to CERN, I went there to give a talk, and then some group of people at CERN organized, I think an intervention is probably the best way to describe it, where they took me into a room with a bunch of different CERN users, and they were like, hey, we really care about reflection. Can you get on board with caring about reflection too? And everybody gave a little presentation about how they were using reflection, why reflection was important.
好的，是的，是的。所以实际上，故事还有一个更好的部分，那就是当我去了 CERN，我去那里做演讲，然后 CERN 的一些人组织了，我想“干预”可能是描述它的最好方式，他们把我带进了一个房间，里面有一群不同的 CERN 用户，他们就像，嘿，我们真的很关心反射。你能加入我们一起关心反射吗？每个人都做了一个关于他们如何使用反射、为什么反射很重要的简短演示。
And I remember you gave a presentation. Yours was, everybody's presentation was good. Yours was better than everybody else's. And I actually was convinced by that meeting, and I went out of that meeting, and I went back, and I went to all the C++ powers. that be at nVIDIA and i was like reflection we got to make it a priority
我记得你做了一个演示。你的，每个人的演示都很好。你的比其他所有人的都好。我实际上被那次会议说服了，我离开了会议，我回去，我去找了 NVIDIA 的所有 C++ 大佬，我说，反射，我们必须把它作为优先事项。
we should uh we should focus some effort on it and uh yeah so so you you convinced me that we should care about reflection and i was like and we should also hire bernard because he's he's really good we got to have him before we hand the mic back to bernard this is real bad because what a lot of listeners just heard
我们应该，我们应该投入一些精力，是的，所以你说服了我，我们应该关心反射，我就想，我们也应该雇佣 Bernhard，因为他真的很棒，我们必须在他加入之前拥有他。在我们把麦克风交回给 Bernhard 之前，这真的很糟糕，因为很多听众刚才听到的是
is if you invite bryce to your corporation you can then potentially get a job at invidio i mean well if you can if you can if you invite me to come to your corporation and then you ambush me and convince me. They didn't ambush me to be fair. I was very happy to meet with them.
如果你邀请 Bryce 到你的公司，你就有可能在 NVIDIA 得到一份工作。我的意思是，好吧，如果你能，如果你能邀请我到你的公司，然后你伏击我并说服我。公平地说，他们没有伏击我。我很高兴见到他们。
But if you stage an intervention and try to convince me if you convince me something, I mean that's pretty, you make a compelling presentation. Presentation is the way to my heart. A good slide deck is the way to my heart. I will tell you that. I have like an awful lot of thoughts in my head. Now I don't wonder like whether I should like publicly speak about it.
但如果你策划了一次干预并试图说服我，如果你说服了我什么，我的意思是那很……你做了一个令人信服的演示。演示是通往我心灵的途径。一套好的幻灯片是通往我心灵的途径。我会告诉你。我脑子里有很多想法。现在我不知道是否应该公开谈论它。
But since like reflection finally got standardized and in C++, 26, I think I can let Bryce in on some of the background of why we locked him up in this room. And the backstory was that CERN founded this open source program office and they wanted to have like a popular figure from the C++ community to speak there. But CERN also has a very big interest in reflection as a feature because CERN develops this C++ interpreter and that kind of like depends on generating metter information on C++ code. and CERN is actually pushing for reflection as a C++ feature,
但既然反射终于在 C++ 26 中标准化了，我想我可以让 Bryce 了解一些我们把他锁在这个房间里的背景。背景是 CERN 成立了这个开源项目办公室，他们想让 C++ 社区的一位知名人物在那里演讲。但 CERN 对反射作为一项功能也非常感兴趣，因为 CERN 开发了这个 C++ 解释器，它在某种程度上依赖于生成 C++ 代码的元信息。而 CERN 实际上早在 2005 年就开始推动反射作为一项 C++ 功能了。
I think as early as 2005. Some people showed me papers, like before C++11, where CERN was proposing reflection. So when one of my supervisors kind of got in contact with Bryce to have him speak at that event, I already made the decision that after the PhD, I'm going to apply it in media, and I told him. And my supervisor told me, look,
有些人给我看了论文，比如在 C++11 之前，CERN 就在提议反射了。所以当我的导师联系 Bryce 请他在那个活动上演讲时，我已经决定博士毕业后要申请 NVIDIA，我告诉了他。我的导师告诉我，看，
we're going to have Bryce here. And one of our priorities would be to just make Bryce believe that reflection is an absolute killer feature. And he should make sure that every power that Nvidia has should just push for reflection to get into the standard. And by the way, Bernard, if you want to impress Bryce, maybe he can put in a good word to get hired at Nvidia. So you do the presentation in that room in front of Bryce and you make a good impression and convince Bryce that we want to have reflection in the standard. and boy I was so nervous and I couldn't sleep for weeks because I know my whole life
我们要请 Bryce 来这里。我们的优先事项之一就是让 Bryce 相信反射是一个绝对的杀手级功能。他应该确保 NVIDIA 拥有的每一份力量都应该推动反射进入标准。顺便说一句，Bernhard，如果你想给 Bryce 留下深刻印象，也许他可以美言几句让你被 NVIDIA 录用。所以你在 Bryce 面前的那个房间里做了演示，你留下了很好的印象，并说服了 Bryce 我们希望在标准中拥有反射。天哪，我太紧张了，我几周都没睡着，因为我知道我整个人生
and the life of CERN depended on the 20 minute presentation I was scared shit sorry shouldn't say that right long has the explicit tag been put on our podcast so one of the things that actually came out of that presentation indirectly
和 CERN 的人生都取决于那 20 分钟的演示，我吓坏了，抱歉，不该说那个，对吧？我们的播客加上 explicit 标签已经很久了。所以实际上从那个演示中间接产生的一件事是
is that the reflection suffered I think in some of the earlier drafts from having not the strongest example a lot of people or making fun of it is like, oh, you can't do anything with this reflection, you can just do enum to string. And one of the reasons is that the current perfectionability, you don't have a way to inject functions yet.
反射在一些早期的草案中受损，因为没有最强的例子，很多人在取笑它，比如，噢，你用这个反射什么都做不了，你只能做枚举转字符串。原因之一是当前的反射能力，你还没有办法注入函数。
Right, it's a static reflection only. You don't have a way to introduce new functions. So it does, to some degree, limit what you can do. But there was a very simple example that one of the uses that y'all had at CERN was using reflection for reordering the field yields of like a struct, like packing or doing like array of struct, destructive array. And that, that example I found very, very motivating.
对，它只是静态反射。你没有办法引入新函数。所以它在某种程度上限制了你能做的事情。但有一个非常简单的例子，你们在 CERN 的用户之一正在使用反射来重新排序结构体的字段，比如打包或者做结构体数组、数组结构体。那个例子我觉得非常、非常有动力。
And so I put that into a couple talks. And then I convince the reflection authors, I think through Andre, that they should put it into their paper. And I would like to believe that that example is one of the best motivating examples. And one of the reasons about, I'd like to think that's one of the reasons why we got reflection. What do you think? That is a great, it is a great origin story, a great Nvidia origin.
所以我把它放进了几次演讲中。然后我通过 Andre 说服了反射作者，他们应该把它放进他们的论文里。我愿意相信那个例子是最好的激励例子之一。我想这就是我们得到反射的原因之一。你觉得呢？这是一个伟大的起源故事，一个伟大的 NVIDIA 起源。
story for brown yeah yeah yeah all right who should we should we got we should get coon on the mic here just for a sec because we mentioned your name earlier and coon is the genesis is the reason you were the one that came up with sean parr it might be like you're you're gonna get sean parrott t-shirts we're gonna have oh my god we're going to make we're gonna make i you know i i told conner a couple days ago i was thinking about making adesp t-shirts but you know just a t-shirt that says a dsp i didn't I feel like it would be enough, but we're going to get t-shirts that have the parrot, parrot on it, but with Sean's face. This is coming from the folks that took five years to get you stickers, and it's not like we had the idea three months ago, and it took us three months. We've been talking about stickers for, like, four of the five years of this podcast.
故事，为了 Bernhard，是的，是的。好的，我们应该，我们应该让 Kuhn 上麦，就一会儿，因为我们之前提到了你的名字，Kuhn 是起源，你是那个想出 Sean Parrott 的人，可能会像，你要得到 Sean Parrott 的 T 恤，我们要有，天哪，我们要制作，我们要制作，你知道，我几天前告诉 Connor，我在考虑制作 ADSP T 恤，但你知道，只是一件写着 ADSP 的 T 恤，我觉得这就足够了，但我们要制作印有鹦鹉的 T 恤，但上面有 Sean 的脸。这是来自那些花了五年时间才给你贴纸的家伙，而且并不是我们三个月前才有这个想法，花了三个月。我们已经谈论贴纸谈了五年播客中的四年了。
I will execute quicker on this. Anyways, well, I mean, technically, we don't need to introduce, Kuhn, because you were on the podcast almost a year ago or two years ago? Only one time. Only one year. Why did you do two? Oh, for two episodes. That's right, because you were at the table, and that got diced and diced up,
我会更快地执行这个。无论如何，我的意思是，技术上，我们不需要介绍 Kuhn，因为你几乎是一年前或两年前在播客上？只有一次。只有一年。你为什么做两次？噢，为了两集。没错，因为你当时在桌子旁，那被切碎了，
as we do on ADSP, because otherwise it wouldn't be a weekly podcast. But... What? There were two recordings? Yeah, there were two recordings. We recorded twice last year? Or here, you explain.
就像我们在 ADSP 上做的那样，否则它就不会是每周一期的播客了。但是……什么？有两次录音？是的，有两次录音。我们去年录了两次？或者在这里，你解释一下。
You take the mic and introduce yourself in case if we have some new listeners since a year ago. Shame on you for not going back to the backlog and listening all 200 episodes since you started listening. We need those, and also two, Right before we give Kuhn the mic, we've recently discovered that, like, the Steve Jobs saved Sean Perrin episode is like the sixth, the most popular Sean episode, and like, I don't even think it's in the top 100 episodes.
你拿着麦克风介绍一下你自己，以防我们自一年前以来有一些新听众。真为你感到羞耻，没有回去听你开始听以来的所有 200 集。我们需要那些，还有，就在我们把麦克风交给 Kuhn 之前，我们最近发现，比如，Steve Jobs 拯救 Sean Parent 那一集是第六，最受欢迎的 Sean 一集，而且我觉得它甚至不在前 100 集里。
If we don't ask for much listeners, we don't ask for much, what I'm asking is that you all go to your podcast player, you don't have to listen to it, just go back, download it from the archive, and then erase it and mark it is played. we need it to be in like the top 10 because it's not okay that's not in the top 100 anyways over to Coon introduce yourself for those that didn't listen a year ago
如果我们不要求太多听众，我们不要求太多，我要求的是你们所有人去你们的播客播放器，你们不必听它，只要回去，从存档中下载它，然后删除它并标记为已播放。我们需要它进入前 10 名，因为它不在前 100 名是不对的。无论如何，交给 Kuhn，为那些一年前没听过的人介绍一下你自己
and maybe tell us about this year's you know C++ Under the Sea experience and also how did Sean Parrott come to you because you're now a part you were already a part of the lore of ADSP but now you're really going to be a part of the lore because Sean Parrott that's brilliant okay so yes my name is Coon and I'm from Belgium
也许告诉我们今年你对 C++ Under the Sea 的体验，还有 Sean Parrott 是怎么来到你这里的，因为你现在是，你已经是 ADSP 传说的一部分了，但现在你真的要成为传说的一部分了，因为 Sean Parrott，那太棒了。好的，是的，我叫 Kuhn，我来自比利时
and well this is actually actually my third episode, because in the first episode I was in, it was actually recording by Tristan. I had a question on CPP On Sea last year. My memory is so bad that yes, we had the episode, I think it was at CPP North, where you had given, or you didn't give, Tristan whipped out his cell phone, recorded your question. I believe it was about unique count and a parallel implementation of that and a possibility of the implementation. He played that for me at CPP North, and then we responded to that, and then we met you here later at last year's edition. I totally had forgotten that backstory. It was, so when you said three, it wasn't two
这是我第三次上节目，因为我参加的第一集，实际上是 Tristan 录制的。去年我在 CPP On Sea 有个问题。我的记忆力太差了，是的，我们有那一集，我想是在 CPP North，你给了，或者你没给，Tristan 掏出手机，录下了你的问题。我相信是关于唯一计数和它的并行实现以及实现的可能性。他在 CPP North 给我放了那个，然后我们回应了那个，然后我们去年在这里的活动上见到了你。我完全忘记了那个背景故事。所以当你说是三次时，不是两次
times at C++ Under the C. It was one time at C++ Under the C. This is now the second and third overall, because Tristan's recording of your voice at CPP North. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, you're very much a part of the lore now. You've technically recorded at two different conferences. How many people can we say that about? I do not know. You would know. You have the data. I mean, basically just speakers, I think, because they're the folks that go to different conferences. Anyways, back to you. What did you think about this conference? And you got any, you got any new deeply insightful questions for us about the podcast? Feedback? Complaints? Pribes? Putting Kuhn on the spot. I don't have any questions for the moment, but yeah, the parroting, well, just, I am now
在 C++ Under the Sea。是在 C++ Under the Sea 一次。这是总共的第二次和第三次，因为 Tristan 录下你在 CPP North 的声音。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，你现在很大程度上是传说的一部分了。你技术上在两个不同的会议上录过音。我们能说多少人做到这一点？我不知道。你会知道的。你有数据。我的意思是，基本上只有演讲者，我想，因为他们是去不同会议的人。无论如何，回到你身上。你觉得这个会议怎么样？你对我们关于播客有什么新的深刻见解的问题吗？反馈？投诉？贿赂？把 Kuhn 放在聚光灯下。我暂时没有任何问题，但是是的，关于鹦鹉的事，嗯，只是，我现在
I have a second daughter now and as things go I can make a lot of dad jokes now so Sean Parrott Congratulations also is this a recent second daughter or February so yeah congratulations
我有第二个女儿了，随着事情的发展，我现在可以讲很多冷笑话了，所以 Sean Parrott。恭喜。这也是最近的第二个女儿吗？二月，所以是的，恭喜。
congratulations so that's why I'm making a lot of dad jokes now and that was one of them that came to mind and what did you think on the conference this year was good I learned a lot about Kuda as well so that was great to get some more
恭喜，所以这就是为什么我现在讲很多冷笑话，那是我想到的其中一个。你觉得今年的会议怎么样？很好，我也学到了很多关于 Cuda 的知识，所以能得到更多关于那方面的见解真是太好了
insight on that and while hearing Sean speak of course has also been a highlight and getting to know the Parrot Library it's funny because some of the things I already also started implementing in our library just because of the ease of use
而且听到 Sean 演讲当然也是一个亮点，并且了解了 Parrot 库。这很有趣，因为有些东西我已经开始在我们的库中实现了，仅仅是因为易用性
to have a simple function to call to have a sum instead of having to call STD accumulate and so on so having the simple interfaces is something that really can help for colleagues and just to have less code to make less mistakes so that's really nice to see uh i mean this this is amazing folks dad jokes is what brought sean parrot into existence and you got to understand is this is going to be a part
有一个简单的函数可以调用来求和，而不是必须调用 STD accumulate 等等，所以拥有简单的接口是真正可以帮助同事的事情，并且只需更少的代码来减少错误，所以这真的很好。我的意思是，这太棒了，伙计们，冷笑话是 Sean Parrott 诞生的原因，你必须明白，这将成为我们未来几年生活的一部分。我的意思是，显然可能会制作 T 恤，我们有 Sean 在这里，他在会议上做了开幕主题演讲，我们得到了他的批准，因为我们不想那样滥用 Sean 的名字，但他觉得这太搞笑了。是的，所以现在它是我们生活的一部分。冷笑话把这个名字带给了你。而且，是的，点求和。我的意思是，关于 API 设计以及符合人体工程学和直观界面的重要性，以后还有机会讨论
of our lives now for years to come i mean uh apparently there may be t-shirts being made uh we had to we shan's here he gave a keynote the opening keynote to the conference and we got approval from him because we don't want to abuse sean's name like that but he thought it was hilarious And yeah, so now it's a part of our lives. Dad jokes brought this name to you. And, yeah, the dot sum. I mean, there's a conversation to be had at a later date about API design and the importance of an ergonomic and intuitive interface
因为我和一些人谈过，他们不一定认为这足以成为一个令人信服的事情。而且 Parrot 不仅仅是这样。但我，我，人们相信更好的接口不足以让一个库成功？有一点，是的。我的意思是，带有一些星号，但是，你知道，你总是谈论切换到一门语言的 10 倍差异。我不知道切换到一个库需要什么乘数，但我听说过那句名言，如果它只是一个改进，一个接口更改，那是不够的。
because I've had conversations with folks that don't necessarily think that that's enough to be a compelling thing. And that's not all the pair it is. But I, I, that people believe that a better interface is not sufficient for, for a library to succeed? A little bit, yeah. I mean, with some asterisk, but, you know, you always talk about the 10x difference to switch to a language. I don't know what the multiplier that you need to switch to a library, but I've heard the quote, if it's just an improvement, an interface change, that's not enough.
但它，但 Parrot 不是。Parrot 的关键卖点是 Parrot 是最大程度懒惰的。这意味着 Parrot 默认是异步的，并且默认进行融合，这两者都是 Thrust 今天巨大的痛点。所以 Thrust 的主要痛点几乎立即被 Parrot 克服了。干杯，Sean。但等等，好吧，让我们和 Kuhn 说再见。非常感谢。这是你第三次露面。以后一定会有第四、第五和第六次。
But it's, but parrot is not. What Parrot, the key selling feature of Parrot is that Parrot is maximally lazy. And that means that Parrot is asynchronous by default and does fusion by default, both of which are the huge pain points of thrust today. So the major pain points of thrust are overcome almost immediately by Parrot. Cheers, Sean. But wait, well, let's say goodbye to Coom. Thank you so much. this is your third appearance. There's got to be a fourth, fifth, and sixth now down the road.
我们马上要和 Sean Parent 对话，你知道，就在中间，是 Sean Parrott。是的，是的。所以 Parrot 的名字，也就是我库的图形标识符，而不是标志，现在由 Kuhn 命名，因为他有两个女儿，最近有了第二个女儿。我们应该解释一下。NVIDIA 有一个团队，一个组织，一个标志。所以没有其他标志。有些东西确实有图形标识符。我确实。在周三，这个库开源的前一天，我确实花了一个小时试图让我的库的图标成为鹦鹉。图形标识符。不，GitHub 仓库的图标。
And we're about to talk to Sean Parent, which, you know, it's like right in the middle, is Sean Parrott. Yeah, yeah. So the name of the Parrot, which is the graphic signifier, not logo, of my library, has now been named by Coon because he has two daughters, a second daughter recently. We should explain. Invitya has one team, one org, and one logo. So there are no other logos. Some things do have graphic signifiers. I did. On Wednesday, The day before this library was open source, I did spend an hour trying to get the icon of my library to be the parrot. Graphic signifier. No, the icon of the GitHub repo.
但它在 NV Labs 组织内，我在三个不同的 LLM 之后确定了，被煤气灯效应折磨了一个小时，就像，噢，你只需要更改 markdown，等等。如果组织设置成你不能更改图标，你就不能更改图标，你不能更改图标。你不能更改图标。无论如何，谢谢 Kuhn 的参与。谢谢 Sean Parrott。我们希望，我不知道，我们明年还会回来吗？也许。
But it is within the NV Labs organization, and I determined after three different LLMs, an hour of being gaslit, that's like, oh, you just need to change the markdown, blah, blah, blah. If the org sets it to be so that you cannot change the icon, you cannot change the icon, you cannot change the icon. You cannot change the icon. Anyways, thank you, Kuhn, for being on. Thank you for Sean Parrott. We hope, I don't know, are we going to be back next year? Maybe.
如果我们明年回来，希望你也会在这里。而且，是的，谢谢你的到来。是的，谢谢你们邀请我。好的。有了这个，我们将过渡到不是 Sean Parrott，而是 Sean Parent。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
If we're back next year, hopefully you'll be here. And, yeah, thanks for coming on. Yeah, thank you for having me. All right. And with that, we will transition to not Sean Parrott, but Sean Parent. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you, you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。希望您喜欢并祝您度过愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是充满混乱与零星信息的播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。